[Música]
maratón diplomática del presidente
francés emmanuel mayor a su reunión ayer
con el presidente ruso vladimir putin
hoy estuvo en kiev y en alemania para
intentar descargar las tensiones
el presidente de perú pedro castillo
juramento a su cuarto gabinete en seis
meses de mandato y tuvo que renovar su
gobierno tan solo una semana después de
la última modificación varios de los
ministros que ha posicionado antes han
sido criticados tenemos información
desde lima
el principal puente que comunica a
estados unidos con canadá está bloqueado
los transportistas tienen parqueado sus
vehículos para protestar en contra de la
vacuna obligatoria contra el kobe 19 el
gobierno afirma que esto tendrá fuertes
implicaciones en la economía
buenas noches y bienvenidos de nuevo a
las noticias de france 24 los saluda mar
y aclara calle y empezamos hablando de
la nueva jornada de diálogo sobre la
crisis entre rusia y occidente
el presidente francés emmanuel marco
visitó a su homólogo ucraniano volodymyr
selenski y le comunicó la pretensión
rusa de no escalar el conflicto poco
tiempo después se reunió en berlín con
el canciller alemán olaf scholz y con el
presidente polaco andrzej duda
una maratón diplomática el presidente
francés emmanuel majo se reunió en
berlín con el canciller alemán olaf
scholz y su homólogo polaco andrzej
ciudad para dialogar sobre la crisis
entre rusia y occidente mccoy afirmó que
los tres países se comprometieron a
encontrar una salida diplomática del
conflicto que usaron consiguiente
seguiremos actuando en las próximas
semanas con objetivos simples el primero
se ha dicho es evitar la guerra evitar
ayer la pelea este de la paz y la
estabilidad del continente europeo son
nuestro tesoro y consideramos que
debemos hacer de todo para preservarlo
y rechazaron nuevamente cualquier
intervención militar rusa en territorio
ucraniano en el fight una violación de
la integridad territorial y la soberanía
de ucrania es inaceptable y tendrá
consecuencias de gran alcance para rusia
política económica y ciertamente también
geoestratégicamente
poco antes el mandatario francés había
usado el mismo tono conciliador en su
reunión con el presidente ucraniano
volumen excellent que aquí le comunicó
las pretensiones rusas de no escalar las
tensiones
sí
sobre las discusiones sobre aspectos
militares y de seguridad
como dije muy claramente ayer hemos
tenido intercambio con el presidente
putin y él me dijo que no estaría detrás
de ninguna escalada
por su parte se les instó a putin a dar
pasos reales para acabar con la crisis
en general no confío mucho en las
palabras por eso creo que todo político
puede mostrar su apertura con hechos
concretos en nuestro caso esos son pasos
hacia la desescalada de escalares a
pesar de la concentración de más de
100.000 militares rusos en la frontera
con ucrania se espera que la apuesta por
el diálogo continúe cuando marco
siguiendo con su rol de mediador hablé
con el presidente estadounidense joe
biden para evaluar nuevas soluciones
el presidente peruano pedro castillo
nombró a un nuevo gabinete esta es la
segunda reforma de gobierno que hace en
tan solo una semana y la cuarta en los
seis meses que lleva de mandato la más
reciente crisis se produjo porque el
presidente del consejo de ministros que
había nombrado castillo el primero de
febrero renunció tres días después de su
juramentación se trataba de héctor
baller quien dimitió tras conocerse que
había agredido físicamente a su esposa y
a su hija nuestro corresponsal en lima
francisco zacarías tiene toda la
información
la situación es simple los peruanos
rechazaron un mejor dicho la situación
del ex primer ministro alto aller quien
prácticamente amenazo al congreso de que
si no obtenían el voto de confianza del
presidente pedro casi no iba a cerrar el
parlamento pues bien casi lo tuvo que
denominar otro equipo de gobierno y
juramento aníbal torres que
anteriormente ejercía el cargo de
ministro de justicia aníbal torres
tendrán que presentarse al parlamento
peruano en 30 días y tiene el reto de
dejar de tener el enfrentamiento
político con el parlamento y reactivar
la economía pero acá no termina la
crisis política a decir de muchos
observadores y analistas esto va a
continuar porque el parlamento no está
convencido con este nuevo gabinete que
no consideran que es de ancha base como
había prometido el mandatario y como lo
había exigido diversos sectores del país
todavía están latentes las amenazas de
vacancia presidencial y también una
acusación constitucional contra el
presidente pedro casi o por haber
ofrecido entregar una porción de mar a
bolivia con acceso lógicamente al
pacífico desde cosa peruana
he notado a cientos de camiones
restringen el paso en el puente que
comunica a eeuu con canadá ellos
protestan por las medidas contra el co
bit 19 mientras al gobierno le preocupa
es que por esa vía se mueve el 25 por
ciento del comercio binacional
los transportistas defienden sus razones
como nos lo explicó david ramírez
colaborador del convoy de la libertad
estamos apoyando el corte convoyes por
primeramente por la libertad de
expresión la libertad a decidir él
para terminar los mandatos marginales
los mandatos de máscaras para que todas
las personas tengan derecho a poder
escoger qué es lo que van a hacer con su
cuerpo las personas no están pidiendo
que no sea contra las vacunas la mayoría
de los camioneros al 90% vacunados están
pidiendo simplemente que terminen los
mandatos y terminen el estado de
emergencia en canadá porque está
afectando a muchas personas en el labio
en el ámbito mental emocional familiar y
también laboral
yo david ramírez soy un empresario
también ha afectado las los negocios los
comercios canadienses la economía la
inflación
queremos simplemente que ya pasemos a un
a una segunda etapa lo que llama la post
pandemia es podamos liberar todo lo que
es las restricciones que se han hecho
durante esos dos años donde los
canadienses han tenido mucha presión
muchos blogs downs muchos cierres de
negocios y queremos simplemente que el
gobierno diga ya basta
un implante aún en experimento podría
devolverle la movilidad a las personas
con paraplejia tres participantes que
tenían lesiones en su médula espinal
ahora están caminando todo gracias a que
el dispositivo estimula los nervios y le
envía pulsos al cerebro el estudio es
liderado por el instituto federal suizo
de tecnología aquí les contamos toda la
historia puede parecer un primer paso en
falso pero para míchel rocatti significa
un mito una primicia mundial hace cinco
años un accidente de motocicleta le
rompió la médula espinal por completo
dejándolo parapléjico pero ahora camina
de nuevo gracias a un dispositivo que
estimula los nervios y envía pulsos al
cerebro y a los músculos
investigadores del instituto federal
suizo de tecnología unieron fuerzas con
una empresa neerlandesa de tecnología
para crear un implante espinal de seis
centímetros horas después del implante
michelle y otras dos personas
parapléjicas en estudio pudieron ponerse
de pie pero toma tiempo acostumbrarse al
dispositivo que es controlado por una
tableta con pantalla táctil
mientras más entrenen más músculos
desarrollarán y más fluido será el
proceso de entender lo que tienen que
hacer para aprender a caminar con esta
tecnología si el aparato no repara las
lesiones de la médula espinal si no
estimula los nervios dañados que no
podían enviar mensajes suficientemente
fuertes al cerebro permitió que los tres
participantes del experimento puedan
caminar nadar andar en bicicleta y subir
a escaleras y si los hallazgos resultan
exitosos en la revisión por pares
podrían suponer un gran avance para los
parapléjicos en aproximadamente un año
empezaremos a realizar ensayos clínicos
fundamentales principalmente en eeuu
para probar esta tecnología en grupos
más grandes probablemente entre 70 y 100
personas
para míchel rocatti poder cruzar un
puente poder ponerse de pie por sí solo
y mirar a alguien a los ojos es un gran
avance una especie de milagro gracias a
la ciencia y tecnología
ya se conoce cuáles son las películas
nominadas a los premios oscar nuestra
periodista especializada en cultura le a
google nos cuenta más desde la redacción
de france 24
una película definitivamente
destacada sobre el resto estos the power
of the dog el poder del perro y sus dos
denominaciones con este western oscuro y
psicológico o netflix quizás tiene por
fin la oportunidad de ganar su primer
oscar de la mejor película es que esta
edición de los premios oscar está
marcada por la cantidad de obras
nominadas ya disponibles en las
plataformas de vídeo por demanda la
espectacular superproducción jim del
canadiense the universe está en el imax
tal como el biopic o richard una familia
ganadora donde will smith interpreta al
padre de las hermanas tenistas venus y
serena williams en apple philip los
pueden ver coda los sonidos del silencio
que triunfó en el festival de cine
independiente de sundance del año pasado
y en netflix encontrarán don't look at
no mires arriba la santidad de adam
mckay sobre el cambio climático y su
casting de estrellas meryl streep
leonardo dicaprio jennifer lawrence por
nombrar sólo algunos encina entre las
películas todavía en las salas y las que
pueden descubrir en la plata de este
niño pueden prepararse de la mejor
manera posible antes de la ceremonia del
27 de marzo
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
gracias por elegirnos
[Música]